super sache wie findet man sich in einem
fremden land zu recht die sprache ist
der schlüssel zu allem das hört man
immer wieder
da gibt's vs kurse sprachschulen oder
lehrbücher oder eine ebenso geniale wie
einfache idee zwei münsteraner hatten
sie schon vor zehn jahren
sie machen kurze interviews auf der
straße und stellen die dann ins netz
also für jeden kostenlos abrufbar
easy languages und diese idee wird
mittlerweile auf der halben welt kopiert
so präsentiert sich easy languages im
internet und dies sind seine erfinder
carina schmidt und jan owczarski drehen
in münster gerade ein neues easy german
video mit dem ausländer später land
leute und sprache kennenlernen sollen
die besten freunde die du hast
kennengelernt hat in der schule ja meine
engsten freunde habe ich tatsächlich
entweder über andere freunde
kennengelernt oder im internet nach den
dreharbeiten folgt die arbeit am
computer jedes gesprochene wort wird in
deutsche und englische untertitel
übersetzt von dir wissen wie die freunde
die heute hast du deine besten freunde
wo hast du die kennen gelernt meine
engsten freunde habe ich tatsächlich
entweder über andere freunde
kennengelernt oder im internet bisher
gibt es über 100 easy germany folgen
in ihm geht es ein wenig auch darum
ausländern zu zeigen wie die deutschen
ticken
wir wollen schon so ein bisschen mit dem
programm einfach dafür sorgen dass ich
menschen kennen lernen dass man andere
ein einblick erhält in andere länder
dass man kulturen kennenlernt und die
leute sich auch untereinander
austauschen
dieses konzept das in münster geboren
wurde wird inzwischen in der halben welt
kopiert
dabei ist es so erfolgreich dass die
erfinder mit der werbung auf ihren
internetseiten sogar geld verdienen
januar schon carina freuen sich dass sie
von einem projekt leben können das
inzwischen menschen aus der halben welt
zusammenbringt teuerster passiert weil
sich die menschen austauschen und das
geht auch manchmal dann über grenzen
hinweg die man die man sonst stärker
spürt dass sich dann plötzlich ukrainer
und russen austauschen dass man auch
gemeinsam arbeitet an gemeinsamen ideen
an gemeinsamen projekten
das ist das ist das faszinierende dabei
so ist das projekt aus münster ein
kleiner beitrag zur völkerverständigung
und eine möglichkeit einmal ganz einfach
in fremde sprachen und kulturen
hineinzuschnuppern
jetzt am wochenende